do you know you have you have a lot of
muslim fans either something came from
nothing or something came from something
[Music]
[Laughter]
kyrie irving the famous basketball
player kyrie on a personal note you have
said that you are fasting for ramadan
which for those who are one of unaware
means no food no water from sun up to
sun down i say like sharia law i say
it's a fisa real law you know it's like
we have were they created by nothing
say like i think both parties are
corrupt both you know both systems are
misleading people you got allahu akbar
on your hat found out the teenagers were
singing allah akbar listen to what said
they say afterwards
you know if you want to control the
minds of the masses like malcolm x said
the media does that so what do you think
when you hear this we say literally we
love jesus to your audience and any
muslim that watches you know i'll always
on my news platform give you a fair
shake i might convert to islam right now
[Music]
which means peace be unto you my next
guest grew up catholic got baptized went
through the motions but his family and
himself really wasn't into it at a
certain point he realized organized
religion which is fishy seemed like a
scam he he ended up taking a leap of
faith and declared himself an atheist
considered himself woke but eventually
he came back to believing that there
must be a creator to all of this he's a
famous youtuber has been watched by
millions doing news analysis
we have mr anomaly himself here on the d
show what's up brother how are you i
guess you saw that video right the one
where i talked about coming back to god
that's what triggered us to go ahead and
invite you on and have a conversation
very cool i'm glad i made that video
that way as well um you know i made it
short and i tried to really make it um
relatable and i knew that christians and
muslims would would appreciate it and
i'm glad that you saw that and and liked
it because i almost didn't make that
video because it's just like a you know
short deep one but it's probably one of
my favorite videos it's hard to tap out
of the news sometimes when everything's
going on but appreciate you having me
really good video really good we'll get
into that i wanted to start off with the
first part that you talked about in that
video that you talk about your family
not really being into it yourself can
you help us understand that first part
that you talk about
so i grew up uh i guess catholic my
parents got divorced at a young age and
i just feel like nobody in my family
really had the spirit right it didn't
seem like they were super excited about
it and as a kid it just seemed like i
was being dragged to places like i think
it's called ccd like go here go here and
i'm just kind of being dropped off
places nobody's excited about god or
you know explaining it in a way that
made sense so something seemed off and
even with like the catholic church you
know you learn about corruption etc on
television
and then i
picked up i think it was richard dawkins
book where he was talking about you know
god's not real it's the spaghetti
monster or something and i just felt
like i was rebelling against society so
that was my rebellion at a young age
like my whole family was
super religious or or claimed to be and
then i was like you know it's all fake
this is a bs and i guess it wasn't until
my 20s that i started to you know
returning i guess lived experiences
watching how wicked some parts of the
world in the media has gotten but uh now
it's crazy i feel like i'm the most
religious person in my family and now
it's the opposite i'm trying to get them
back on the train so i mean we we did a
180 almost as a family
you talk about at stage like when you
accept you
took a i call a leap of faith you know
you became an atheist right right and
now you considered yourself woke what do
you mean by that
well i guess
i guess i felt like i knew activism very
well when i when the atheist thing i was
real cocky i remember i would go around
the kids that believed in god i mean i
was kind of a jerk now that i look at it
but i was like it's stupid i don't get
it where does the soul come from your
dog has a soul i would just kind of
bully kids now i wasn't a bully but
asking questions i guess and just being
a little rude and then i guess college
you know they they got me with a lot of
the
you know certain activism and social
justice stuff and i'm not saying social
justice isn't real i just feel like the
media manufactured version of it tends
to be kind of fake and you know they
they tap into the fact that a lot of
kids want to change the world right like
as a kid you're like something's not
right you see the prison system this i
something's off so i feel like the media
and certain groups know how to tap into
that hunger that i had and i think as i
grew up i started kind of seeing through
the cracks more and more and being like
okay well
and i think that's one of the qualities
that really helped me grow was i had
humility and i wasn't super stubborn you
know which i'm grateful for and i always
try to tell people no matter you know
how smart you are not i mean most people
have i think the capacity to lower their
ego and just
listen to new ideas right and not
just write them off so i started
learning that not everything was what it
was so that's i guess woke used to mean
you know i'm awake to the banking system
you know it was a good thing and now
it's considered a bad thing to some so
i've seen
that that brand kind of just shift
because you the reason i ask you that is
because when people think now okay now
i'm an atheist they go to university
many christians and even muslims they'll
go to university and the whole system
kind of is set up to push their agenda
and to get you to become someone you
know who is like away from religion
religion is some fairy tale you know so
you have a lot of christians will go in
and this is like a true story they'll go
into the philosophy class and the first
day of class they'll be like how many of
the professors like how many people
believe in god everybody raised their
hands the christians the muslims and
then at the end of the day those who
aren't really grounded what happens is
at the end of the class now they're
pushing the whole narrative that there
is no god and everything on you and then
at the end
the semester
it's very few hands that stay up you
know right and though now some people
attribute not believing to god like oh
i'm woke i'm cool now right right now
that's definitely happening in culture
especially college system they have this
huge political social agenda where you
know they act as if god is this archaic
belief but you know i've been telling
people recently whether you're white
black christian muslim whatever you are
you know they're trying to push this
idea that all of history's evil like
your history's evil it was only slavery
like that's it and you read these
ancient texts and it's so much wiser
than the people nowadays so all these
like halfway professors you know they're
almost teaching a new religion to people
they're taking the void of religion and
their religion is their activism and
social justice and now it's gotten so
lopsided like i don't care how big or
small you are but they're almost pushing
this idea that you know being massively
overweight is like amazing and if you're
working out it's like a far right wing
it's getting so looney tunes where it's
like that you know there's nothing wrong
with working out that's not really a
political angle so i think they're
really messing kids up and
you know any muslims or christians
watching this going going to school or
sending your kids to school definitely
try to be involved because you know
they'll screw your kids up real fast
have you seen that documentary it's
called intelligence uh no intelligence
allowed expelled
i haven't really good documentary it
shows this where people now the
professors people who argue for
creationism for a creator they end up
when they go against the system they end
up getting
pretty much blacklisted right so it's a
whole push that if you go against the
narrative right then you're not invited
to the party anymore right well yeah i i
really strongly recommend our viewers
you if you haven't watched it it's
called it's done by a christian actually
it's called expelled no intelligence
allowed put that on your to-do list if
you have a chance cool i have a quick
story real quick um
i went to west virginia university and
this was before i think the social
justice push got extreme um but i guess
it was still there so i had this
professor who seemed kind of gay but he
would always say i'm not gay i'm not gay
like no one asked but he'd always say
that which made me think he was because
i never asked and he told me that's like
a hundred times but he made us write a
letter to barack obama at the time and
he said write the letter here's your
assignment write a letter to obama and
say why you support gay marriage and he
didn't allow you to not and i was
thinking at the time even though i
didn't have these huge social stances or
religious dances i always thought that
was just weird just as somebody who was
could critically think i was like what
if somebody's religious and doesn't
agree with it i i believe they should be
allowed to make the case for why they
don't support it you know even if that's
not what i agree with but he conned
really everybody into forcing them to
believe this whether they did or not
write it or else they would fail and
then he took the letters and mailed it
to the white house and acted as if we
had done that organically and just felt
that way and i even as someone at the
time that didn't have a big stance on it
i felt very duped i was like wow this
guy's a sneaky you know like political
agent almost just getting thousands of
kids to write letters that we didn't
even have an option to disagree with so
that just shows how crazy it was even
back then it just kind of slipped under
the radar
do you know you have you have a lot of
muslim fans a lot of muslims that watch
you you know share your material did you
know that
i mean i don't know the exact number but
i i figured over the last couple of
years i've seen a lot and i appreciate
it yeah so i've had a lot of people uh
also tell me to invite you on the
program share a lot of your stuff and
the
the community is going to be happy to
that we got you on the program i'm
pumped i saw your jesse lee peterson
interview and i feel like you and your
brother there handled it very very well
you know jesse uh you know he makes some
good points definitely but he you know
he definitely has his mindset and he's
sticking to it where i think in the
right wing christian conservative
whatever you call it sphere you know
people are very
i would say misinformed about islam you
know and i i feel like that i'm one of
the few people that gives it a super
fair shake beyond fair shake i
compliment it often so i appreciate that
people see that and you know i thought
that's what made me want to do the
interview i was like you guys handled
yourself super well thank you very much
and that's what we try to do we try to
you know go ahead and explain islam in a
simple way and i feel that we have a lot
in common with conservative christians
we really really do you know and
you uh you talk about a lot of those
things but it would just on one end you
have we feel sometimes islam is so
misunderstood muslims are so
misunderstood on one side you got groups
that just want to kill us they want to
or eradicate us they don't have nothing
to do with muslims but i feel like if we
work together we can accomplish much
more good like many of the things you
talk about for instance you talk a lot
about abortion you know what i mean so
that's that's one thing that we have in
common you can work on you know you you
talk about so many other um good things
but the division if we're divided you're
going to be you're not going to be as
efficient what do you think on that no i
agree and i think that it's still slow
because i think like the fox news people
are and i'm not just blaming fox news
but they're you know they've been
programmed for so much but i think a lot
of younger right-wingers are starting to
respect islam in a way that they never
did because you know during the patriot
act and the iraq war it's almost as if
they use the entire religion as a
scapegoat where obviously there's some
bad actors and the crazy part is when
you get to really the core of it it's
not to take you know 100 responsibility
in america and act like we're so bad but
a lot of the really radical groups that
are the minority are being funded and
supported a lot of times by the west you
know it's almost like they're egging it
on purposely so i think a lot of people
are realizing now that we were promised
this whole you know war on terror and
now they're turning inwards and they're
looking at you know white christian
conservatives as if they are now the new
al qaeda i think a lot of younger
conservatives are starting to realize
like you know they'll look at muslim
countries and say based that's based
because they realize okay they're
putting a a stop to the degeneracy and
in the stricter muslim countries they
put their foot down hard where in
america they they're it's almost like
they don't put their foot down at all so
i think there's this new respect for
islam and uh and even the christian and
american world where they're like okay
wow they you know they have
kind of halted leftism by taking a
stricter stance than uh american
conservatives if we just take that
example with jesse since you watch that
do a lot of people also sympathize
you know
with the way he or see things the way he
does when he kept pushing certain points
he kept pushing this thing about takiyah
and your quran teaches that for to lie
deceive and then we're giving him
references we're giving him textual
proofs you follow me but he keeps on and
then i start to think about okay i start
to feel a little bit you know sorry for
people who've been because you also talk
about this you talk about media
manipulation how the media you know
brainwashes the people have but then i
look at many conservative christians
that they know the term fake news right
but then when it comes to islam you're
going to swallow everything you know
bait hook sinker everything right well
it's like you got to be consistent you
know there's a lot of push with lies the
store should have truths but uh so what
do you think do do a lot of uh
conservative christians also uh believe
like some of these things that we find
like just crazy that he really believes
this stuff and he's convinced of it
i have to say with jesse he's he's like
he's a unique character where it almost
seems like there's nobody like him just
the way he carries himself because
he's so you know when he wants to ask a
question he'll ask it 15 times like
so it's almost comical you know that's
what makes him entertaining and
interesting and a lot of times it works
but not definitely a lot of people i
would say that number's shrinking yeah
because of what's going on in america
and the war on terror i feel like people
are starting to realize nothing that
they said like we're going for bin laden
but now we're in syria and libya and now
you have like intelligence agencies
looking at trump supporters as if
they're the enemy so i think that was a
big wake-up call but definitely you know
i hear that a lot um there's just a few
talking points like you said the takiyah
or the you know this and that and i i
try to say you know i mean i don't
always have like
a conversations about this because i
haven't really heard it recently but you
know as far as the idea that everybody's
violin or that that one was around for a
while with that propaganda it's like you
you would know if that was true just you
know logically because there's billions
of people on earth that
follow this religion um you know so i i
think
i think definitely there still is a lot
of right-wingers that believe it because
of that you know war on terror sort of
like
15 years of just like pushing this
narrative one thing that stood out from
you and that video and i want to go
ahead and share it with you
and then with your permission i want to
show you something that came to my mind
and get your reaction to it can we do
that
absolutely does that really make sense
either either something came from
nothing or something came from something
it's hard to really say that nothing
coming from nothing oh it's just the big
bang or planets colliding or whatever
well then where did those planets come
from where did it start what came first
the chicken or the egg okay so that's
the first part that's the one
video that triggered
me and i'm sure a lot of muslims will
relate to what i'm going to show you
next i just want to get your reaction
with your permission yeah no worries
because remember what you said
and then
you're going to let's see if you can put
it together and then just get your
reaction to it we're going to start from
the number 34 but it gets into at number
35 and pay attention to the to the words
and to what you said
[Music]
[Music]
then let them produce a statement like
it if they should be truthful
um
[Music]
[Laughter]
or were they created by nothing or were
they the creators of themselves
let me hear i want to hear what that
means to you like exactly you know
because i i get it it's very similar but
yeah so
so the verb did they create the heavens
and the earth
so here we go when you talk about
when you talked about
something
either something came from nothing or
something came from something
so here when i
heard that i right away came to this and
i thought about this question that's
asked or were they created by nothing
right
[Music]
so did nothing create nothing
right and then your logic was that had
you come back to belief in god was that
uh nothing nothing cannot produce
something right right right so this had
me think of that
uh here so because a lot of the
scientists they you know they're like oh
that's so dumb to think there's a god
but that but the big bang ha it's like
well where did that you know so that was
definitely like where did that come from
then it just that came from nowhere how
does that make any more sense now this
do you have you ever heard this have you
ever now and i'll break it down for you
but this is just for educational
purposes
did you do you know what you just
listened to
have any idea no
what does it sound like to you because
you're also a musician so you're good
with uh musical instruments and that
what what did it sound
like
i'm sorry
yeah so this is actually this is the you
know you had jesus who spoke aramaic i
just like to frame this you just better
understand uh
jesus peace be upon him he spoke aramaic
he didn't speak english so if we were
going to try to trace something back to
him we would go to that language a
sister language
to aramaic is the language of uh
the arabic language semitic languages so
this this is what the quran was revealed
in
and i i say that just because sometimes
people attribute when you say arabic oh
that's just for the arabs or you know
what i mean uh so now for a better
understanding this is actually the quran
yeah i'm not i'm not really like a
close-minded person so i i mean that's
kind of crazy to say everybody's only
for arabs i mean it's
an ancient language i mean definitely if
you can't read or write it you're out of
luck but you know i'm i'm a appreciator
of wisdom and i know definitely even you
know i'm i'm not in i'm not like a
taoist or a buddhist but i do like the
tao te ching you know which is like a
you know a lot of like eastern
philosophy and uh you know i like stuff
like that and i could separate it where
i could you know a lot of even
christians get upset at that like oh
what is that your religion and i'm like
you know only and i'm like i just you
know i could browse it and it doesn't
you know it doesn't make me want to make
it my whole life thing i'll i'll give
you an example like if you were to put
something like your hats and you have
another hat that's on your profile
really cool and i'll i would say like
you got allahu akbar on your hat you'd
be like no i don't know
yeah
all right right right together right so
but a lot of times you'll see the news
outlets they'll like show people saying
found out the teenagers were singing
allah akbar listen to what said they say
afterwards
i i have a problem uh helping those
people out they'll be like
god is the greatest exactly and you got
hats that say god is the goddess i know
i i did it and i it wasn't even like a
purposeful thing but i i was thinking
about what i was going to do for my
branding and i could have done a lot of
stuff but i felt it was more selfless
and even with this hat i always like get
in conversations like old ladies that
are like oh i like that hat it's a real
conversation starter and i knew when i
made the goddess great because
once again a lot of right wingers are
ignorant and they don't know that that's
what allah akbar means is god is great
so i figured i was like you know this
would be a great hat for a muslim as
well and uh you know i was i was joking
to my friends i was like i should
translate this into arabic and just put
it in arabic and then and then right
wingers will really freak out but that's
definitely the problem the sales will go
through the roof brother
yeah i i know i probably should but i
guess that's you know a lot of a lot of
brainwashing where they don't know it
means that and i guess you know they
they have identified that once when some
people do stuff when it's a small
minority of people that are committing
acts you know they say that so they have
then you know tied it where i guess
that's where i see you know left wingers
when like say like a motive happens like
there was the guy in new york and he had
a lot of like racial feelings this is
not to blame everybody of his ethnicity
but that's that was his motive you know
where the left-wingers will say oh we
don't know his motive and it's like it's
right on youtube you know and so that's
like the both sides are very childish
the left winger will act like we don't
know the motive at all and the right one
will be like well he said that or you
know that's how he felt but but both
sides go extreme i feel like and then
like the left doesn't want to talk about
it and then the right wants to blame
everybody and it's frustrating when
you're not uh you know when you're not
like a partisan hack you're like man
this is like it it feels very childish
and i'm i'm only in my early 30s i'm
watching like 50 and 60 or 60 year olds
act like kindergarteners and i'm like
this this can't be real
it's kind of like saying hallelujah
right
but same thing yeah uh get let's get
into uh you talk also about about uh
kyrie irving the famous basketball
player
kyrie on a personal note you have said
that you are fasting for ramadan which
for those who are unaware means no food
no water from sun up to sun down
how do you muster the energy to go out
and score 34 points with very little
nutrition in your body
well it's a journey with god and i'm not
alone in this i have brothers and
sisters all around the world that are
fasting with me
uh we we hold our prayers and our
meditations very sacred what do you
think when you see someone like that a
lot he talks about fighting for freedom
but recently also you see him
somebody who the news reported on
him
fasting during the
being able to score at such a high level
what do you think if someone is not
who's not yet muslim muslim you know
when you see something like that what
are your thoughts impressions well with
the you know the injection i'll just say
i i think it was very honorable that he
took his stance and you know didn't cave
when that's how he felt as far as the
ramadan the fasting and the islam you
know as somebody as i grow up i really
respect first of all i'm into health and
stuff and i understand the you know
health benefits to fasting
but i respect the discipline of of
muslims and i think that christians in
america
they don't have the discipline they had
50 60 years ago and i think that's
what's destroying you know uh christian
america is the the discipline compared
to old christians like non-existent so
you know muslims the the uh the
discipline to fast and the health
benefits of it and also the you know
subservience to god and the uh the
constant appreciation of it i i i think
that's honorable and i uh yeah i i think
i think it's it's definitely tough to
play at a high level like kyrie because
you know you're you're doing the sports
against the best people and he's just
he's doing great but i think his soul
and his spirit's in a great place and
you know he feel like he won he he beat
big pharma with the help of god and the
help of uh you know i guess just not
caving to the to the system is that one
of the sports that you're really more
into is basketball i do like basketball
yeah i like all sports but i would say i
watch the nba probably more often than
others you had a nice tweet here
and this is another thing
that i wanted to ask you about
so the regime teaches you the
prohibition was wrong think about that
for a minute you don't learn personal
finance in school but they are sure to
let you know that banning alcohol was a
great mistake and not to be repeated
again that took me home in a whole
different world you know and i'm always
connecting things in this in a certain
way
right i don't know if you want to hear
how i connected it first or if you want
to go ahead and just elaborate no i want
to hear it but i want to say that's
that's mike cernovich i retweeted it
he's always okay so yeah i just shared
it he he did that mike is a very
insightful person and i just thought
that was uh oh i see okay certainly his
thought process there was fascinating so
i gave it a retweet because i was like
that is interesting right that they
teach you about prohibition but they
don't teach you personal finances that
is a little odd who's he i i i okay i
see you retweeted that okay
he actually he's
because cernovich
cause i'm from bosnia so
[ __ ] usually
he is a he's definitely a more
right-leaning analyst but i have to say
when it comes to islam and right wing he
definitely is a muslim respecter he is
not he does not disrespect muslim i
think his wife might be muslim i'm not
sure but uh out of everybody like hill
you know he's one of these people that
is unpredictable that's why i like him
he he doesn't just say there's some
people it's copy paste copy paste right
they have no the mind they're just happy
but he's not like that he's always
saying wild stuff and even when i
disagree i find i find it fascinating so
yeah i want to hear what you think about
that it right away took me to a point in
time in history where you did have the
prohibition that america saw
what alcohol was doing to
society humanity into the country to
home so
they used their logic and they were like
hold on this is something that is not
good we're going to try to get rid of it
but
you know that was a law
but it didn't get into the hearts of the
people so the people fought against it
now it connected me to the time of
prophet muhammad uh peace and blessed be
upon him and this was when the
revelation the quran had come down in
stages it the rules and regulations
didn't just come down it's not just a
rule book you know this is wrong this is
prohibited first it connected people
hearts to their creator to one and only
one god
and then the day of judgment paradise
hellfire i'm trying to convince this
make it real quick and then
when first it said don't come to prayer
intoxicated it came in stages but when
the when the the verse came and said
that alcohol is totally prohibited their
faith was at a level where they it's
narrated that people who were drink who
had just had the alcohol in their hands
they threw it down
the ones who had just swallowed they
spit it out and literally they said the
people who had took a chunk and
swallowed
they were regurgitating it the streets
were filled with alcohol people just
getting rid of it right and to this day
you know the muslim majority countries
you'll see you have the least amount of
alcohol consumption
because of their devotion to one and
only one god to the creator heavens and
earth because in their hearts so it
reminds me when you try to just do
something you know with without having
the people's hearts into it then you
have you have this result but when their
hearts you know when they have a love
for their creator and they know who
their creator is and then when the
creator tells them to stay away from
something because
he knows best and it's harmful for you
then you end up uh hopefully obeying
that you know so that's another thing
that's interesting and i think that's
i've watched certain documentaries and
just i mean experiencing as well but you
know
a lot of people think the politicians
are really guiding policy because in
some ways they're writing the laws et
cetera but the media the culture the tv
shows the movies you know that's
shifting the minds of the masses and
then they could take something like say
gay marriage that was unpopular on both
sides 10 years ago and through
programming on television now it's you
know basically
the the right has become the left and
left has become the further left so the
the media really you know if you don't
have god you don't have religion in this
country and all you have is like
television and movies and you know i
think that's that's what's going on here
with a lot of things where in the virus
lockdown they had you know you can't go
to the gym you can't go to the building
you know you got to be also sorry to cut
you out but you know you got you got to
be careful with what words you say and
whatnot because then the videos get
taken down so yeah yeah no i won't i
won't say anything
there's a lot of alcohol ads on
you know a lot of alcohol ads on on the
um television and a lot of fast food ads
where i just found that fascinating that
people were thinking well
you know um
maybe if there was a government
intervention and authoritarianism
allowed now maybe mandatory workouts or
maybe they you know if they had
a conscience maybe they would take off
alcohol ads right if you could shut down
a beach then maybe you could but they
kept the alcohol ads pumping for sure
that's crazy you do a brilliant job of
breaking down you know
the media manipulation and almost like
putting people into a trance
and
a lot of muslims also have fallen into
this trance like they'll know i'll give
you an example for instance like when
you bring up something like uh you know
the
the buildings coming down for instance
on one end you have islam condemns
killing of innocent men women and
children this is clear there's no doubt
about it right
uh that's a whole different topic i've
done so many shows on this
but then when you see
a building coming down right and nothing
hit it you're following me and then you
see christians uh coming forward and
also uh saying you know that
um you know this this uh architects and
engineers etc etc so this muslims will
understand that okay these are lies you
know misinformation or when you talk
about palestine for instance you know
you'll see that there's also media
manipulation lies but then when it comes
to other certain things again they'll
swallow it hook sinker just like the
topic that you kind of just alluded to
so can you talk talk about it can you
elaborate you know uh
on this media manipulation how strong
just how strong it is and it's almost
like magic
it's it's crazy strong and with the
internet it probably always was with the
television but you know everything is
kind of rigged where on google on
youtube if you were to search you know
say like donald trump or something
you're not going to find a video of
donald trump speaking for himself you're
going find you know the 15 news sources
that they have approved news of what
they're saying of him and whether people
like him or not just the idea that you
know we're not even allowed to hear
certain people speak for themselves it's
almost like they're branding everything
all the time so with big pharma for
instance you know there's heavy
censorship with social code now if you
speak about gender in the wrong way you
could have your whole channel taken down
you know what regardless of your
religion so it just keeps getting more
and more censorship so
speaking out against these political and
social narratives is becoming almost
illegal i i say like sharia law i say
it's a fisa real law you know it's like
we have uh we have pfizer sharia law or
you know you could question god in
america but you can't question big
pharma it's it's fascinating or vouchy
you know
uh so
i think um the the the social engineers
and powerful people in society have
always figured out in the same way that
elon musk is trying to buy twitter i
believe maybe for the good but um you
know if you want to control the minds of
the masses like malcolm x said the media
does that so they have figured out
through movies television and the social
narratives are crazy so i wanted to ask
you too because i know in in america you
know a lot of muslims are are more
left-wing and definitely becoming more
liberal but i you know i'm no i'm not an
expert of the quran but it you know
similar to the bible it's almost like
the antithesis they're teaching the
opposite values you're right
and kids are falling for it because
they're being told if you're a bad
person if you don't do this i mean it's
literally like inversion you know like
if you follow the works of god and you
follow these principles discipline
principles that are actually like
definitely better you know you're the
oppressor so you know just side with us
that you know whether it be the rainbow
flag whether it be the blm whether it be
the environmentalism things that people
are like well of course i i don't
support racism i i want the earth to be
clean you know it which i do but that's
how they kind of there's all these
little traps to just bring you over next
thing you know you're you're rejecting
god so we're kind of making history here
because that's the whole idea you know
we want this to be something in his
example that's why
i ended up doing that interview with
jesse uh trying to break through many of
these stereotypes
and
people can hopefully god willing they
can see us as an example
that we are able to talk we're able to
communicate
and we're able to ask questions and
hopefully you know we're able to because
to go back to what you're saying
why this is what we've seen is that many
muslims are scared they feel like on one
side literally these people want to
eradicate us they want to kill us they
want to you know they don't have nothing
to do with us right over here they're
inviting us you know they're inviting
the muslims right they're petting you
they're you know but they're stabbing
you in the back
so it's like but definitely here we have
what you have much more in common much
more in common and you mentioned the
term and i just want to for educational
purposes
uh when you you mentioned the term
sharia this for on for the non-muslim
audience it just means god's law this is
like the ten commandments pretty much
uh you have shadia mentioned i had a
jewish rabbi on the program and he
talked confirmed this and in the arabic
bible you have shariah mentioned 200
plus times
just just like you have uh allah
mentioned in the arabic bible in arabic
jews and christians who read the bible
in arabic
it's not doesn't say god it says allah
right so sharia same thing it just means
god's law that's it and sharia is
charity prayer how to be a good husband
the rights of the wife of the husband
many people they look at the penal code
which is just one percent of islam
following just one percent and probably
most people would agree with many of the
strict because the penal code is there
it's very strict to uh to act as a
deterrent you follow me to keep
criminals in check but
good human beings who are living a good
righteous life they shouldn't have to
fear these things right and i just had
uh i had uh i don't know if you heard of
this uh andrew tate
you can watch the show that i did and he
he's traveled and many he's a christian
also and he travels to he's traveled to
muslim countries
and you should check out what he has to
say on on this on
this topic that we're talking about how
much respect i have for the
faith of islam and i'm not a muslim so
i'm an orthodox christian but
if i had to bet on one religion as if i
were betting on the stock market for the
future you have to bet on this mom but
anyways let me let me just get into some
of the other things that that you talk
that you talk about can you elaborate
what's being injected into the kid's
school curriculum you had this new uh
bill
that was being passed and and you uh you
uh
did
some videos on you did a video on this
and analyzing this can you bring us up
to speed yeah so the governor of florida
passed a bill i'm sure it was
multi-pages but the gist of it was i
don't know if it was like
nine to five or if it was elementary but
it was pretty pretty young and it just
said you know don't teach kids sexual
education don't don't inject sexuality
into the minds of the children basically
um and then the you know the left wing
in this country kind of freaked out and
said don't say gay don't say gay even
though that's not the name of the bill
it was kind of just like a branding
attempt to smear it and uh that's what's
kind of i'm seeing is uh you know as far
as people's identity and who they are
when you're especially i mean there's
conversations to be had about adults but
to me this is like crossing the line way
too far you're six seven years old i
thought i was a power ranger a ninja
turtle an athlete a fireman you know i
don't really you don't know what you are
because you're so young and really all
you know is what your parents teach you
if you know if i speak english because
my parents taught me english it's not
like i thought to speak english you know
you're literally like a sponge being
molded by your parents and your teachers
so you have a lot of these people
that are trying to inject sexuality and
confuse kids into thinking they're a
different gender and it's just so
disingenuous at a young age because
they're they're too young to even know
anything so i think what's going on in
schools is you know similar to why the
kids and i appreciate you saying that
because it is tough for a muslim in
america on one hand the right wing is
not open on the on the other hand the
left wing is kind of stabby in the back
so it is like a you know there is really
a difficult decision to be made um but
as a kid it's like they're really
teaching these kids you know if you're
gay you're like special and you know if
your skin color is this your your
history is bad and it's almost like a
safe route to just like say you're a
different gender or something you know
it's like safer to be like well i'm you
know i'm like i can't be bullied now
maybe they'll call it hate speech and
it's it's just way too confusing for
kids so ron desantis is one of the
republicans pushing back against that
and disney and and the left wing kind of
freaked out and mislabeled it and and
it's it's really upsetting because if
you disagree with what he's saying i'm
willing to hear the debate but what they
do is they kind of straw man make up a
fake argument that's not had similar to
like people do to you you know it's hard
to have a conversation about islam if
people are making up something that's
totally false it's you know that's
called the straw man it's like here's
some
fake thing that i'm gonna fight with
that's not even real so yeah it's that's
that's kind of the thing they're doing
with the kids pushing sexualization
you know gay gender switching on like
five-year-old six-year-olds yeah i
brought on a actually a great woman her
name is brenda lipscott she's a
christian also and she's this is another
great example and she's working with
muslim imams and muslim community
leaders and i've had around the program
exposing
them
uh what they're doing and putting these
things real subtly a lot of times into
the curriculum and you have some you
know many parents some who are
immigrants they have no idea right
what's going on and and then they end up
uh also
at a certain age where like you said a
child's like thinking i'm a ninja turtle
this that the other they're confused and
then they say like just take your time
and we'll put you on what are those
puberty blockers right right right just
screw up your whole physiology and your
biology and just
mess you up totally
yeah it's it's really sad and it's nice
to see someone like yourself who's uh
bringing this to fruition and
helping people see what's going on it's
tough to talk about because the you know
the right-wingers that take a hard
stance it's like they're they're
basically saying it's like a hate speech
violation to
question some of this like if you if you
aggressively say well how how if you're
just questioning if you're like
it's it doesn't make sense
scientifically
by from biology none of it makes sense
that
you know a
a man tomorrow a boy
is born
born
with certain
parts with certain crotosomes everything
that he's a man he's a
boy but now to convince him that he's
other that a person is now a fish or the
person is now a
dog you think that's crazy well coming
back to the religious aspect of it too i
have to say like i think both parties
are corrupt both you know both systems
are misleading people but the left wing
it's it's almost as if they're creating
this religion like like that's why i
joke and say faiza really fauci law
because it's like you they're literally
making it illegal
in certain cases to question basic
reality or talk about basic humanity and
it's it's such a wicked system because
they are they're authoritarian they're
not even like normal liberals like maybe
i'm wrong but you have the right to say
it you know it's it's like i'm they're
they're doing wickeder and wicked or
stuff and that's how they stop people
from stopping them right it's just
saying well that's hate speech maybe
that's racist that's sexist that's
xenophobic that's a conspiracy theory
that's a you know they have a word for
everything to kind of like put up a
block uh that's homophobic obviously
that's a main one that's anti-semitic
that's a climate denial they they hide
their agenda behind things that seem
good and then you know use these words
to stop people from pushing back where
it's like you know i mean 10 years ago
homophobic meant you didn't want gay
people to get married which wouldn't
even be true because it doesn't
homophobia that doesn't mean you're
afraid of them like oh my gosh there's
one you know it's it's that was a lie
anyway but now it's like they've moved
to the children's stuff and now they're
like using that word to block it and
it's like whoa that's you know the
slippery slope is real and i think
that's why a lot of christians and a lot
of uh conservatives i would say millions
of conservatives have a more favorable
view of islam now because they've seen
the slippery slope in america it's real
so i think they're appreciating even in
some of the stricter countries like oh
yeah maybe that is how you stop this you
know how maybe that is how you stop the
degeneracy because every christian
pastor that warned us that this was
going to lead to this i mean it really
did happen i didn't think it would 20
years ago but it definitely has i mean
you know they have gone that far for
sure and this is why muslims and
christians need to work together
right another great example well i think
you know without getting too much into
it i i think it's been a purposeful in
my perspective studying the world and
stuff when you have this sort of
degeneracy this godless uh like you
could say far left but there's
right-wingers doing dishonest stuff this
really evil agenda i think the people
that are doing this have understood well
in america who's voting conservative
against big government you know it's a
lot of white people it's not to say all
white people are doing but you know
there's a lot of this well you're bad
you're bad because they've realized
that's not their voting bloc so if they
could subvert that voting block get
power then they could turn their backs
on all the minorities that that helped
gain them in power you know same with
christians and when you go to the middle
east i mean who's rejecting the
wickedness harder than islam so i think
you know they've turned christians and
muslims against each other it's not to
say that you're going gonna agree on
everything and in certain cases it's
okay you know my opinion to have your
own culture have your own identity
everyone doesn't have to be everyone all
the time it's not like they force people
together but then make them hate each
other it's like it's okay to
live in a different community but um you
know i think they've purposely done this
because they see christianity and
islamists that you know to the biggest
threats to their subversive degenerate
you know evil agenda of you know a
massive i think government across the
world where it's not based by god it's
not based by morality it's almost the
opposite it's almost like you know the
invert inversion of what everybody in
their heart and soul knows is moral is
what they're trying to do so they've
they've definitely subverted christians
in my opinion in america to
really uh you know
align with the group of people that
really doesn't like them the most and
it's it's the exact example that you
said it's and malcolm used to say it too
where it's like you know there's the
person that's going to stab you in the
front and stab you in the back you know
there's something respectable about the
one that's doing it in the front you
know at least you know it's there and
you know to avoid versus the one that
says you're my best friend come in my
house and they hate you so
just a few more questions before we
conclude so how do you feel because i
think this is a good icebreaker i think
this is something that you can build off
when we as muslims and again muslim
simply means it's an arabic word that
means one who has submitted his will or
her will to one and only one god and
islam is the action of submitting
your will gaining peace getting purpose
and light by submitting your will to god
that's what it simply means so as a
muslim how do you feel telling uh
because you be classified you'll be
classify yourself as a christian correct
so as a christian one that you love
dearly is jesus so if i tell you as a
muslim i love jesus it's an article of
our belief to love do christians know
this that muslims love jesus not as a
god or a literal son of god
metaphorically right okay but we love
jesus i mean if i said anything
we say peace be upon him right old
chapter in the quran named after his
blessed mother muslim woman if you look
at them they're wearing the hijab mary
mother of jesus she wore the hijab you
know so what do you think when you hear
this we say literally we love jesus
i mean i know that muslims appreciate
jesus i don't think a lot of christians
do but i'll bring that up because like
when the christian muslim jewish you
know people have debates and this and
that i'll say you know like and i'm not
going to say all because there are some
jews who respect jesus but i always say
muslims on average respect and
appreciate jesus far more than jewish
people do uh you know that's just a fact
because uh you know there's always like
inter religious debates i know that i
think some do but
yeah i would say most don't to be honest
um yeah i would say most have no idea do
you think this is important i mean do
you think this is a good icebreaker
knowing that
for me i mean you know when you when you
love and appreciate jesus as much as a
christian does i think it's i think it's
massive you know when i found that out i
was like oh that's interesting and once
i started really you know with the
degeneracy blockers where you know you
have right wingers being like we need to
go to palestine and and make gay
marriage illegal and i'm like that's a
christian trying to go to palestine and
make it like i was like we have enough
problems here why would i try why would
i want as a christian to go to palestine
and make them gayer when we're having
like drag queen story hour and pride
parades every month like that's what i
that's what christians want like the the
right-wing republican party in this
country has been so subverted it's it's
bananas you know like literally that
that's like their talking point so
between that and respecting jesus these
are things that made me realize like
okay i'm like you know there's there's
some there's something not adding up
about what they've said about it but i
think that's a massive massive
icebreaker and if like you know you're
speaking to a christian who's hostile i
mean it's not your job to make them not
that's on their soul and spirit but i
think that's definitely a talking point
that would you know
maybe wake some people up but it's hard
to tell some people are so stubborn and
they never learn and they never listen
and you know there's old saying you can
lead a horse to water but you can't make
them drink but i think that's a good
place to start for sure i think
christians can start to understand now
because they're they're seeing you know
their way of life they're seeing all
this new religion that's pushed for
their liberalism and everything and
they're like we don't need this stuff so
you can imagine like muslim majority
countries you're trying to go over from
other side of the world coming over
there and trying to
impose your way of life on them
right and they're like we don't need
this over here you follow me
we're good so oh man is a man we don't
need to right mixed
i don't want to be a fish or i don't
want to right right or whatever else you
want to call it so i think people and
this is going to be
real i know they stop it more but
they're going to they're going to try to
i mean they already have but infiltrate
muslim countries and the slippery slope
goes slower there because muslims put up
a blocker but they're going to try to do
that further and further too you know
like just like slowly over time try to
get muslims to be more liberal and you
know as as somebody i mean you you live
in america correct yes yes yes
the slippery slope is real do not let
the western liberals convince you that
it's not because it happens quickly
where are you in the states i'm in
california california you ever travel to
chicago
i've never been okay if you do we can
hook up have you in the studio in person
that's where we're at chicago all right
i'll let you know if i ever do okay last
uh one i wanted to touch upon
you you talk about
the
you show a clip
and it's discussing abortion
and it talks about the i don't know
whether it's a politician or someone he
talks about after the baby's delivered
then we can have a discussion right and
many muslims are also blind to this this
also what's going on and you're you're
bringing this to the forefront like talk
about this
so i'll start real quick without getting
too wordy like just like with god you
know pro-life pro-choice it didn't
really mean much to me growing up and i
thought there was a moral discussion
going on okay when is it sperm egg when
is it a baby i that's a complex
discussion right because it would be
wild to say your sperm is a baby when
it's not so a lot of christians think
conception whatever uh
it was the left wing just moving it
further and further so it's like okay
well they're mad at the heartbeat and
then it's like 14 weeks and 16 weeks and
third trimester and i'm thinking of
myself as someone who never thought
about it i'm like that seems a little
weird wouldn't you know like that's a
little and then you have ralph northam
he was the governor of virginia before a
democrat and he was on some radio show
and he said we'll resuscitate the baby
which means like bring it back and then
like basically allow the mother to make
a decision or something and i guess he
was saying if the baby had some sort of
illness or something but still i mean
you know i don't think if something is
alive it's alive it's not your job to
murder it so they've moved this once
again just like with the lgbt stuff they
move the slippery slope so far they're
not simply trying to have a moral
conversation about when it's alive and
when it's not they are suggesting in my
perspective after birth abortion which
is just
full-blown
murder i mean it's it's it's
evil
yeah definitely this is uh you know
islam stance on this also right
i'm i'm not 100 let me know like what
the popular opinion is in islam yeah the
majority consensus is across the board
default is that it's not allowed
abortion isn't
you have up until
according to the hadith from prophet
muhammad peace and blessed be upon him
who he talks about the soul you might
have the the body the heart pumping and
everything but at
120 days that's when god blows the soul
into
the
the child the baby
uh so up until then without extreme
exceptions right if
you know and then that's up to they will
go to a qualified islamic scholar and
see what these exceptions are right uh
let's say the mother she
her life she might die you found me
maybe she was right whatever there's
exceptions but the general rule that
it's
it is prohibited definitely it's a human
life
and at 120
days according to islam it has a soul
yeah so you have the you have the the
soulless taking you know these because
you where's your soul you have to ask
yourself
right you've seen these videos they come
in and they're just removing body parts
you know what i mean at six months seven
months it's crazy it's crazy right
that's another great talking point
because i know a lot of christians a lot
of right-wingers it's a very passionate
topic you know there's the pro-life
march in dc and it's enormous they never
cover it in the media but it is it is
huge i was even shocked by how it looked
like there were a million people there
so it's a it's a popular thing that the
media has kind of written off for years
but i think the reason is so popular is
not just islamic christianity but it's
human nature right like if you have a
soul and you see body parts or after
birth like it's it's a natural human
thing to protect the young yeah i want
to thank you for accepting an invitation
to be on the dean's show god willing we
can continue the conversation that other
people can take from this example learn
from this benefit and to see hopefully
could be a catalyst for others to take
off with and have more conversations and
do more good working and collaborating
together between muslims and christians
and just all good humans
cool thank you so much for having me and
i have to say uh to your audience and
any muslim that watches you know i'll
always on my news platform give you a
fair shake and uh you know be as honest
as i possibly can because i know a lot
of people are dividing lying you know
spreading really just hate bad energy
and they don't know what they're talking
about so i'll always give you guys a
fair shake and be as honest as i can
really really appreciate that and that's
that anomaly right that's correct yep
thank you brother i appreciate you man
god bless you god bless you thank you
peace
and i want to thank you guys for tuning
in here on the dean show
that was a really great discussion hope
you guys got to enjoy it i surely did
subscribe if you haven't already to get
more so you don't miss
opportunity when the next video comes
out and we'll see you next time here on
the dean show
peace be with you assalamu alaikum i
cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you are not yet muslim and you're
tuning in to see what these muslims are
talking about and you'd like a free copy
of the quran go and visit the
deenshow.com we'll take care of the
postage and everything and get it
delivered to you and if you still have
some questions
about islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you assalamu
alaikum and if you like this episode of
the dean show like this video
share this video
far and wide and support us on our
patreon page so we can continue this
work
thank you for tuning in peace be with
you assalamu alaikum